it's the land of the free home of the
brave and the death penalty the United
States is number five in executing
people after these guys China Iran Iraq
and Saudi Arabia 32 states still execute
their prisoners and lethal injection is
the poison of choice but European
countries who abolished the death
penalty and pharmaceutical companies
have stopped selling prisons the killer
drugs recently there's been a string of
botched executions with experimental
cocktails and states are now scrambling
to execute by other means in these
states you can select the electric chair
in these and maybe sudhi's you can opt
the gas chamber in Utah and maybe some
Wyoming they'll bring you a firing squad
and in Washington you're free to be
hanged
you